nick woolsey's name is absolutely
legendary in the POI World he's
responsible for teaching thousands of
poi Spinners how to use the prop but
more than that he's a man who completely
changed the way that we spin perform and
navigate the POI world so I thought I
would take an opportunity to drill down
why Nick is so important and all the
things that we have to thank him for
[Music]
thank you
Drex here from drexfactor POI sharing
with you the love of poi spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and in this video I want to tell you a
whole lot about the guy who inspired me
to start this Channel and why I think
we're all still living in his shadow but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroterra light toys spin balls
and Ultra POI for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non-business
friend of the channel Becca beckonen
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission so first
up we definitely have to catch up
anybody who doesn't already know who
exactly is Nick Woolsey Nick Woolsey is
a Canadian POI spinner fire dancer flow
artist and on online educator who is
famous for his online tutorials flow
Retreats and a POI video that radically
changed the landscape of the flow world
back in the 2000s that video dervishly
yours was perhaps the first viral POI
video in an era before YouTube even
existed and it catapulted Nick into
worldwide Fame in the very young world
of the flow Arts after its success Nick
explored a variety of different means
for teaching his techniques for spinning
poi from owning a dance studio in
Vancouver to shooting one of the first
instructional dvds for POI and oh yeah
he started a YouTube channel called
Playboy too with more than 18 million
views as of the recording of this video
The Playboy channel was the most popular
destination for people looking to spend
POI online for nearly a decade and a
half and Nick's name became nearly
synonymous with learning POI through
online tutorials Nick retired just a few
years ago due both to injury as well as
wanting to move on and do other things
with his life but he definitely lives on
as one of the Giants in toy history and
education and this is just scratching
the surface of Nick woolsey's Story I
had the privilege of interviewing him
several years ago for my profiles and
POI Series so if you'd like to learn
more about next life and career I'll go
ahead and leave a link down in the
description as well as up in the cards
if you're watching on YouTube if you're
familiar with his work it's certain you
already like and respect him but I think
we sometimes forget that his impact goes
far beyond his tutorials in fact I'd
argue that Nick radically changed what
modern POI spinning looks like and that
we are all still working from the
example that he set nearly two decades
ago more than that he created a template
for flow Arts based content creators
like myself to find careers and have an
impact on the world so in this video I
want to take you through some of the
many ways that I think Nick's influence
continues to reverberate through the POI
world and indeed The Wider world to this
day starting with Nick's style of
spinning poi
for people who came into the POI world
after the tech POI revolution of the
late 2000s and early 2010s it may come
as something of a shock to take a look
at what POI spending actually looked
like before that POI was spun in a
fashion that was typically agnostic of
the perspective of the crowd looking at
Old footage of people spinning in this
era they were as likely to use wheel
plane as they were wall plane and
frequently planar orientations that were
everywhere in between to say nothing of
the fact that everything was weaves
butterflies or other tricks that involve
tucking the hands closely to the body in
a nearly immobile fashion so it's not
hard to see dervishly years as being the
first modern POI spinning video in a lot
of different regards first up this was
one of the first uses of the now common
Convention of treating all POI tricks as
though they were in wall plane
displaying as large a volume of the
poised movement to the audience as
possible
second Nick made extensive use of poi
flowers in his performance it was as
though he'd thrown out the classical
Cannon of poi tricks and started over
from scratch Nick spent years and I do
mean years trying to spread the gospel
of poi flowers as a means of gaining
complete freedom of movement with the
prop of learning to hold the arms open
rather than crossed whenever possible
and of flattening the POI relative to
the audience to give them the best
possible picture in some ways Nick was
kind of the right person at the right
time in this regard as sharing online
video became one of if not the most
common form of popular media amateur
video favors a two-dimensional style of
spinning that essentially flattens the
movement of the POI relative to the
audience Nick happened to work on
popularizing this style right at a time
when it was perfectly suited to an
emerging format for Content nowadays we
take all these conventions for granted
they're not unique to a specific style
of poi they're just how POI is spun in a
modern context and it does need to be
said that Nick was far from the only POI
spinner that was approaching the prop
this way but he is definitely the person
who did the most to integrate this
approach into educating people on how to
spin the prop and normalizing these
conventions whether or not you learn POI
from Nick's videos you almost certainly
learn POI from somebody who themselves
learned from Nick's videos and I can
just about guarantee that because of
that you spin a lot like him as do
thousands of other POI Spinners all
across the world but that's not the only
way in which Nick had a major impact on
the world of poi spinning nor on me as a
flow artist in fact I'd argue that
another one of his major Innovations is
so widespread that we completely forget
the role that he had in establishing it
so let's talk about how Nick built his
online business
I recently had a chat with some folks in
the gloving world and it was really
eye-opening to realize just how much
media around gloving has been filtered
through just one company they launched a
wide variety of different personalities
Technologies fashion and more how my
gloving friends asked would their art
continue on without this company in the
mix and I honestly found that question
to be kind of odd because for all the
time I've been in the POI World we've
worked in such a way that individual
artists create their own unique channels
and Brands to have a direct line of
communication with their audience and
fans and I cannot think of many POI
Spinners who did more to establish this
model than Nick will say think about it
how many of us became established in the
flow arts and more specifically POI
spinning by creating channels where we
share flow videos tutorials reviews
Etc we introduced the world to our
personality on camera and create a
relationship with our viewers where they
feel like like they're hanging out with
a friend for viewers that want to
support us we offer affiliate codes with
popular prop making manufacturers online
courses where people can learn from
lessons we've spent years refining or
attend Live Events and learn from us
directly and if you're listening to all
that and saying to yourself but directs
that sounds more like what you do then
guess what you're not wrong but where do
you think I got that idea from in the
first place who do you think I was
cribbing notes from and whose career do
you think I modeled my own on this has
been really powerful for our community
too it means that there's no single
company or entity that has a
Stranglehold on access to the POI world
there's nobody we all have to go to in
order to pay homage or earn the Goodwill
of in order to build an audience or
start a career it means that the POI
world is personally driven rather than
company driven we connect to people
instead of companies and don't get me
wrong there are both positives and
negatives to that approach but I
definitely owe my own career to the
breakthroughs Nick achieved as an
independent artist and well influencer
Nick was one of those a decade before we
even had a word for that idea and I
really can't get over the fact that this
happened by accident Nick was working on
another instructional DVD and running
into a lot of Technical and storytelling
hurdles so to fill in the time he began
taking requests for tutorials and
posting them on his YouTube channel
those tutorials built his presence and
career and showed countless other POI
Spinners on their way up myself included
how exactly to build a presence online
it also has to be said that the core
products that Nick offered all centered
around one specific facet of the POI
world that he's also had an incalculable
impact in learning and education
before the start of YouTube there were
only two ways to learn POI spinning you
could learn in person from somebody who
knew the basics or you could buy an
instructional DVD and work your way
through the lessons contained on it to
us nowadays that probably sounds
ludicrous how did this art ever grow if
access to learning was this hard to come
by
well the answer is very very slowly
but all that changed for those of us
coming up in the POI world now there is
an embarrassment of riches when it comes
to educational resources online not only
are there tutorials for nearly
everything under the Sun but you have
access to multiple approaches to
teaching the same trick from a multitude
of different voices and perspectives and
that all started with Nick he is the
reason so many of us have gotten the
chance to learn POI online and that is
way more powerful than you might think I
can't count the number of comments I've
gotten from people learning POI from my
videos who live in what are referred to
as flow deserts places where there are
no other POI Spinners or other flow
artists for hundreds of miles around and
yet thanks to access to online video
they're still able to learn how to spin
this is an incredibly powerful tool to
have when it comes to growing a
community it means an art can reach
places that people who practice it might
otherwise never set foot in it means
people can learn the art regardless of
their access to people people or even
finances it means that growth in the art
can become exponential and there's no
limit to it and that has had both good
and bad impacts on the flow Community
the level of access and the focus on
creating educational resources has meant
that we grew rapidly for more than a
decade and brought a whole lot of new
people into this world on the other hand
it also means that learning now is
frequently self-directed and people
might learn similar Concepts years apart
simply because they interact with the
information at different points in their
journey in addition many have pointed
out that it's led to a homogenization of
poi as a style while there are some
regionally specific styles of poi out
there by and large there is a
consistency of stylistic conventions
across not only language and culture but
also continents as well we kind of take
this for granted now but it took having
a popular figure in the POI World
centering their online presence around
creating tutorials to make this a
reality in short it took Nick Woolsey
carving out that aspect of to flow
culture as a recipe for growing an
online presence for any of the rest of
us to get there and it also has to be
said that Nick influenced not just where
we go to learn POI but also how we learn
POI I'm one of many people that learned
watching Nick's tutorials that it was
helpful to not just demonstrate a trick
but to give people detailed walkthroughs
on how to perform them sometimes this
involved coming up with other familiar
movements to compare the POI tricks to
sometimes it involved coming up with
clever metaphors one of Nick's great
skills as a teacher was to approach
learning POI from the perspective of a
complete novice and finding great ways
to break through whatever blocks they
may have to learning whether they be
physical or mental he offered up
detailed lesson plans that took students
through multiple stages of
accomplishment getting down one skill
that would inform another skill each one
eventually leading to the goal that they
had in mind at the start he didn't
invent this method for teaching but he
made it the default way that POI educate
creators like myself have approached
teaching the prop ever since if you've
ever learned POI by building from basic
skills to tricks and then more complex
skills you're working in the mold that
Nick pioneered in our world so to
summarize even though he's no longer
active in the POI World Nick Woolsey has
had a deep and long-term influence on
the artistic conventions business
conventions and educational conventions
of the POI world we owe a lot to him and
not just for creating videos that were
fun and informative he also helped
influence the character and direction of
poi spinning and the flow Arts it says a
lot that despite being banned from
traveling to the United States fairly
early on in his career Nick was still
able to amass a massive fan base here
nonetheless and in so doing he
revolutionized how we all spend and how
those of us who do it for a living can
go about doing so so thank you Nick for
all the gifts you've given us they are
perhaps more wide-ranging and
comprehensive than even you now just FYI
there is an extended version of this
video available now to my subscribers
over on patreon that has an additional
section on how Nick influenced the
theory of spinning for other props
besides POI you can go check that out
over at patreon.com
drexfactorpoi what's your favorite Nick
Woolsey video and are there ways that he
influenced the POI world that I forgot
to touch on leave me a comment and let
me know if you got anything out of this
video please make sure to like comment
share and subscribe to help other people
find it and to help my channel grow
[Music]
thank you
foreign
this video would not be possible without
the kind support of all of these
wonderful people right here these are my
flow patrons over on patreon they and
the people listed down in the
description help to make this video and
all the videos on this channel possible
thank you one and all for your very very
generous support and if you out there
watching are not currently a supporter
but you'd like to become one you can do
that by heading on over to patreon.com
drexfactorpoi and signing up there
you'll get access to a whole host of
awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring POI spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world do check
that out please and thank you if you'd
like to see some interviews I've
conducted with a variety of figures in
the POI World Nick included I'll include
a link to a playlist of my profiles and
POI videos down in the description or up
on screen if you're watching on YouTube
also the YouTube algorithm thinks that
you might like this top video here so
maybe give that a look as well would you
like to see me do another video like
this for another personality in the POI
World leave me a comment and let me know
who for now make sure to get out and
flow and I'll see you with a new video
real soon thanks for watching peace